[Musique]
de temps en temps on en parle c'est quoi
pour vous sa femme
les scénarios qui conduisent à la fin de
l'espèce il n a fin du monde
apocalyptique reverra en collision avec
la terre en direct les pays rupture
énorme de la quotidienne la spirra du
développement multiplie les pollutions
on est certain que la paix rhdp elle
s'arrêtera les princes et les rois eux
mêmes montés les mois
[Musique]
toutefois il va rester quoi maintenant
que ça y est c'est la fin du monde il va
rester quoi tout ça sur les flancs des
collines où démarre disparu à labelliser
des routes désertes arpenter des ruines
à contempler des piles de tous ces
machins que l'on tenait tant est qu'ils
n'auront plus aucun sens et des images
et du thym d'image il était une fois la
fin du mois une sitcom autant d'archivés
de souvenirs de fantômes de notre monde
avant la fin j'ai jamais mais n'est pas
comment c'est la fin du monde on en
parle depuis quoi depuis le début en
fait les apocalypses les ragnarok et
tous les jugements dernier c'est un
grand classique des religions assez
efficace pour tenir les gens par la peur
ou en leur promettant un nouveau monde
au début du siècle on venait encore
toquer chez vous pour vous en cause et
vous donner comme objectif de vie que la
fin du monde est proche
bientôt je sais pas quand mais bientôt
ça je trouve ça vachement marsan la fin
du monde ou plutôt les freins du monde
puisque personne n'était d'accord là
dessus on pouvait aller les chercher un
petit peu partout où leur trouver des
milliers de cause plus ou moins tiré par
les cheveux se fendre de savants calculs
pour trouver une date précise
on s'est appuyé sur des prédictions
cryptic d'anciens astrologues et même
d'autres
un ancien quelque chose d' enflammer
allait venir sur paris tombait dans la
tombe du ciel parce que les gaulois ont
toujours eu peur que le ciel leur tombe
sur la tête et c'était une pour moi et
pour ma mission c'est fou ce qu'on
pouvait interpréter de travers partir
d'un calendrier poussiéreux laissés là
par des types disparu on avait carrément
une date je reprocherais au service
d'avant le second ne pas avoir donné
exactement la date de la fin et puis
même des lieux où les gens éclairés
pouvait aller se réfugier en masse au
fond la fin du monde c'était un
rendez-vous et toujours repoussée à
moins que c'est d'un autre monde et on
devait faire la fin du monde ici mais
quelque part c'est vrai qu'il y en a qui
ont droit à leur fin du monde
les adeptes d'une secte l'ordre du
temple solaire se sont suicidés lankaise
sur place de même lempire maintien sauf
que leur apocalypse bas rhin c'était
nous et ça ils n'ont pas vu venir où les
dinosaures même exterminés par un
cataclysme
enfin exterminer vraiment comme quoi
s'est jamais vraiment la fin non
à partir de la fin du xxème siècle il y
en avait quasiment une d'annoncé et tous
les coins deux ou trois ans et à chaque
fois bouffe l'apocalypse nous posait
encore un lapin alors les fidèles se
dispersait où se trouvaient des bonnes
excuses
renaud marhic spécialiste des sectes a
convié les survivants de l'apocalypse
pour un bon apéritif et vous savez les
gens pas besoin de leur trouver un vieux
bouquin moisi des civilisations
anciennes où je sais pas quel jugement
divin pour les faire flipper avec ça si
ce n'était est sérieux on pourrait
croire que c'est une blague
les concepteurs dominateurs n'ont pas
prévu le passage à l'an 2000
si rien n'est fait d'ici le 31 décembre
tout ce qui ressemble à un ordinateur
sur la planète tombera en panne quelques
mois de préparation auront donc eu
raison de la version moderne des
angoisses millénariste je sais pas
pourquoi on allait chercher toutes ces
idées saugrenues
c'est pas comme s'il n'y avait pas eu
des raisons solides de s'inquiéter de
guerre mondiale ça a quand même son chic
pour vous donner un bon avant-goût de la
destruction totale et non de bruay
à partir de là on savait que la fin du
monde on pouvait la faire tout seuls
comme des grands
vous vous rendez compte comme des
décennies où l'humanité entière craint
une apocalypse nucléaire pense elle a
frôlé à plusieurs reprises et se
demander à chaque instant à temps on
serait quand même pas c'est ma boule et
puis l'événement que personne n'avait
vraiment osé rêver le mur de berlin tôt
il a bien fallu la fin d'un monde pour
calmer les esprits enfin quoique
évidemment depuis on sait que la fin du
monde n'a pas eu lieu à cette époque que
l'histoire a poursuivi son cours sans
quoi nous ne serions pas là pour vous a
parlé d'un évidemment mais cette vieille
peur elle elle est restée le cocktail de
mondialisation hyper industrialisation
surconsommation c'est simple c'était la
peur de tout de ce qu on respirait de ce
qu'on nous fait surtout
la peur des autres l'épidémie globale
qui ferait passer la grande peste pour
une méchante grippe hidemi
d'encéphalopathie bovine spongiforme pas
facile à dire
ironie du sort l'humanité a toujours
gober des tonnes de paranoïa farfelue
mais elle est restée perplexe quand
c'est devenu réel on parlait de on a
beaucoup parlé là mes croyances de foi
de superstition etc
mais on se rend compte que des
scientifiques et par des mois commence à
réfléchir à ce que pourrait être la fin
du monde comme si c'était plus facile
d'imaginer l'apocalypse que disons le
dérèglement climatique qui pouvait
véritablement nous rayer de la carte ou
d'envisager sérieusement l'épuisement de
nos ressources comme ce si précieux
pétrole pour lequel on aimait tant se
battre comme si on n'était plus capable
d'imaginer l'effondrement qu'un autre
système économique ont préféré se
préparer à la fin du monde plutôt que
d'inventer des façons de l'empêcher je
le dis papa d'une organisation
paramilitaire
mais j'ai des armes et j'ai des amis qui
ont des armes chercher y échapper en
fait jamais vraiment été notre truc ou
alors chacun pour soi et après nous le
déluge ravidat je sais la question vous
allez me pose est est-ce la fin du monde
et bien c'est une très bonne question et
je vous remercie madame reposer
je sais pas mais je pense jamais à la
fin du monde car si son père vit
tellement belle grâce à la fin ça
rendrait bien les problèmes et mes
soucis
sa venue trouver de tout je ne vais pas
partir la première mais je t'en reste la
dernière
[Musique]